the ending of episode 9 of andal was
insane and just shows you that you don't
need big cabios or a lot of action to
create such an awesome scene that gets
you hyped up for the next episode so
throughout the episode and or kept
asking Andy circus's character how many
guards in each level to which he never
gave an answer to because his plane by
the rules he doesn't want to defy the
guards and he just wants to follow their
orders and do the right thing so he can
eventually finish the sentence and then
get out of there and also throughout
this episode there was this lingering
mystery about what happened on level 2
because someone took place there and we
don't know what happened and it's not
until the end of the episode where this
information is revealed and then we
found out that everyone was killed on
level 2 because someone who finished the
sentence was transferred from Level 4 to
level two people level two found out
about this and then they'll all killed
to try silence them so once Andy
circus's character found out that no one
is really leaving this place he finds
the answers and or's question when he
says how many guards are there and he
says never more than Twelve sparking and
force shadow owners soon to be rebellion
in the next episode so it's just this
build up and change of the character
Dynamic and the simple dialogue line of
never more than 12. I don't know it just
got me really hyped up what do you guys
think I thought attention in this
episode was just fantastic which
continuously kept building until we got
to the last dialogue line which then
planted a seed for the next episode so
let me know what you guys thought of
this episode in the comment section
below and if you haven't already please
do consider subscribing thanks for
watching guys